look you're not alone you know I think
as you were to split my depression is
feel so personal and all of her stories
feel so personal I wanted to say like
look you're not alone you're reaching
out to me for advice I go through the
same thing and then but this is what I
do to get over it this is what I do to
get better again and again I returned to
the same thing and look I'm the guy who
came up with this and look I stopped
doing AI got lazy and and then you know
when something hard happened I kind of
fell apart right and talk about
embarrassing talk about feeling shame
you know like I'm supposed to be the guy
yeah well I never sent out to be the guy
but like I wrote the book on it right
and like that was from my experience and
I wrote it from my experience and so I
want to share that as well like look
like we will there times when we when we
fall what do we do we step up again and
knowing what works and we do it again
let me go back at it that's part of life
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by Kemal rava can come all
welcome the show thanks for having me
absolute pleasure to have you on man
I feel like we're gonna have something
really special in front of us today I
hope I hope too I hope so too man
hope to live up to it ya know so first
things first you had a bit of a turn
recently and you you were dead for a bit
what yeah for a bit what happened
this is about two and a half months ago
I was I went in for elective surgery
just to fix an old old injury and that
involved like moving some arteries
around and like tweaking arteries and
right before being I was being
discharged from the hospital the main
artery they worked on the the sutures
came off so the whole thing burst and I
basically bled to death and the other
thing that saved me was I was still in
the hospital and I was and at Bert were
so hard that pulled up at my body and
then burst out of my body
not out of sutures just from the force
of the blood and the only thing that
saved me was I was spraying blood
everywhere and so you can tease you a
little bit like a garden sprinkler
system but just hey you know that's
that's a great analogy that's and you
know what our artery goes it's a one-way
street you know in a real artery goes
just a one-way street and and they
managed to get me right away into an AR
and go in and and you know fix it and it
was a rough experience man and like I
literally was gonna experience the whole
like you know like this is it your brain
just goes into primal mode and because
it's trauma it's not like and there's
nothing peaceful about it it just goes
through the images and feelings and
emotions and just like horror because
you mind's not designed to see blood
spraying out of your body like in large
amount and and you can feel it you can
feel yourself like shutting down you can
feel very quickly like just the vitality
or whatever just leaving just none and
you're never been thinking those words
it's looking back that I'm adding words
to the experience there's no real words
that really happened it's more like
emotions and images and
there's a few months ago so you know as
we tried it before
the podcast now I'm healing and I'm
rebuilding my body and and yeah so it
was a bit of a turn with a bit of one
that I wouldn't recommend if you can
avoid it you know can I ask where it was
coming out of you where was the incision
lower abdomen okay so like right in the
alien vs. predator like kind of like
that the most obvious place for it to
happen as well man what a what a
terrifying experience are supposed to
have when you are on the cusp of
releasing a piece of work that you feel
is so valuable and you've worked towards
for so long was that
will you cognizant sufficiently
cognizant to think like not now
now you're just your brain just doesn't
know what to do
I mean in trauma your brain just doesn't
know what to do it goes into primal mode
just feelings and emotions and images of
who's important to you comes up real
fear I've never tasted real fear in my
life that was a real fear came up
because it's like this is it and then
it's hot and it's a horrible way to go
and and so there were no cognizant
thoughts oh I have this left of that
left none of that regrets of the dying
any of that because it was too fast so
but what was interesting was the book
when I get out of it and I I was in the
hospital for a while you know in severe
narcotics and healing and just to get
out of the hospital hospital is a
terrible place at this man
like you're you're healthy guys he'll
get a kick out of this like I mean
hospital food in the u.s. it's like it's
designed to give you diabetes you know
like I was I was refusing their meals
and they were like why I'm like hey take
a look at what you're giving me you know
what it's like how is this gonna help my
body heal like giving a you know a bagel
a piece of cake and orange juice it's
like the it's you know you're literally
the design to give you diabetes you go
in healthy and you come out with
diabetes
I was literally like and they were they
couldn't understand why I was skipping
meals I was like I can't eat this
garbage like I my body needs to heal and
so I got out of the hospital I think a
week later and I was an immense amount
of pain and I was in severe narcotics
for a week and I was supposed to be on
much longer you know the surgeon said to
me look if anyone qualifies for these
drugs it's you you've had like you view
your your you know your body me you need
it you're in a lot of pain and but a
week later when and look they definitely
helped they make things easier you just
kind of like a lie around and you know
in pain but you can bear it and you're
kind of like it and I kind of like
floating not even floating but it's like
it definitely helps and a week later I
have enough cold turkey now why I didn't
need to go off cold turkey I mean I
could have weaned myself off I could
have been on them longer and I'm a cold
turkey and I was in a lot of pain was
because I turn in the final draft of
this book to the publisher and now they
were sending me the proofs when they lay
it lay it out on the page and things get
changed then you know they'd been to
copy at us and this and I had to go
through and review the proofs now if I
didn't if I didn't do them like no one
cares as much as the author does you
know I carried down to every single
comma I care about the feel of the words
and in the mind right and so I had to
and I realized I was trying to do with
narcotics and I couldn't my brain was
too slippery like I'm I mean I guess I
couldn't nobody well my brain wasn't on
it right so I went off him and I had
something bigger I had something bigger
than my pain to focus on that was more
important than the pain so I just went
off woman and I worked on the on the
galleys word by word by word and like
the next one would come and I would work
in a word by word by a word and it was
something more important than what I was
going through in the moment and it was
an amazing lesson as well you know I
remember I wrote a little Instagram post
about it called purpose is bigger than
pain and as a bunch of people reached
out to me privately it said like look I
was I was hooked on narcotics opioids
and and eventually took like me getting
involved in something
caring about something that helped me
get out of it I had one person got very
very mad and said you don't understand
you know like this and you know I was
just sharing my experience and I really
do believe that look you know that's
what made me go off him so anyway that
was the experience with the book but so
it wasn't in in the moment as I was
dying you don't have that you don't have
time for that when you when it's like a
really fast thing but it's like a really
fast
sudden completely unexpected thing what
we think and I think because the way
it's dramatized in movies right it's
like there's gonna be this moment where
I'm able to reflect the Epiphany will
come and I will be able to appreciate
all the things you know if someone has a
near-death experience which is I mean
you are to beyond death experience like
if they have the it's dramatized and we
get this impression that's what it's
gonna be it's gonna be a beautiful thing
because I mean I think it could be if
it's but I think in trauma it's
different your brain just goes into like
primal brain because I've had time we
sit back and think about it you know and
and it literally was it was just you're
going into shock and horror and and
feelings and emotions and realizing your
brain doesn't go this could be it your
brain goes this is it and so it's like
literally trying to stop it and there's
nowhere to stop it
you know how much please I didn't count
but they told me a lot too significant
income amount I mean I was spraying
blood everywhere and sick till the time
that govern you are you know and and -
and it pulled up enough to burst out of
the body which tells there was already a
lot lost you know so I'm still quite
anemic my body's still making red blood
the red blood cells so managing levels
come and go but I'm getting better I'm
taking iron supplements which I've never
had - and eventually eating a lot of red
meat which I'm it's just funny of
doctors telling and I eat a lot of red
meat rebuild your iron stores yeah
strange the way that many medicine comes
full circle so I think it's so
poetically ironic that a book which the
process of once helped you to transform
your life which the
reflection of twice helped you to take
yourself out of a lesson that you'd
forgotten and the purpose of publishing
a third time has been your reason to
transcend the most traumatic experience
that you've been through in your life
but this thing this book is is the
anchor that you're attached to at least
it seems like that in the recent history
of your life that's a very interesting
way to put it I don't know if it's
anchor I'm attached to it's not it's
something I feel a strong obligation to
you know you know this version that
we're pointing out to this is the second
version of it the original version was a
short little book I put out seven years
ago and that took off and and changed a
lot of lives and saved a lot of lives
you know have the emails and I met the
people you know that show me that this
version is like okay I held back a lot
and I you know I have the coaches for my
readers that show that where they were
struggling that I need to show that you
share everything that works and even
share where it doesn't work with me when
and why and how to make that work so
it's special I it's it's more of a
responsibility I feel like and I've it's
a responsibility and it's so interesting
man I I had am I'm saying coffee but the
journalists today and I was telling her
that it's so strange that I'm alive then
I'm gonna get to see this book go out
because I basically almost exited the
planet without seeing and go out it's so
it's a strange feeling man I yeah it's a
strange feeling yeah yeah this is the
only way to Friday I know it's there is
something whether it's an anchor whether
it's the wind in your sails whether it's
the kite you're attached to whatever it
might be there is a a single lineage a
string that is attached to this
particular work that is pulling you
through life in one way or another yeah
yeah and that is momentum that's
insightful man I hadn't thought of it
that way
that's quite insightful
hopefully that's not gonna be the last
thing that we have an insect so we've
skirted around it for a while love
yourself like your life depends on it
to the listeners you will I often have
authors on to talk about their books and
although we are talking about the book
today the purpose of this is not to do a
breakdown of like how to love yourself
like your life depends on it I think
that the way that the book made me feel
and the topics that it talks about are
worthy they're more worthy of a deeper
discussion and that's not - you know
lambaste discussions that do talk about
the book in in sort of more of a order
transactional manner but this this I
think has some real far-reaching
implications so I'm looking forward to
getting into it today and the first
thing that I would say that I noticed
was or the word that I felt when I was
reading it was vulnerability like an
absolutely uncompromising degree of
vulnerability it felt sometimes to me
like standing on the edge of a building
that I knew very well and seeing
problems seeing fears go by so talking
about the fact that after going through
a breakup and making these promises to
yourself even within the time that were
that we're dealing with which is only
maybe a month or a couple of months or
whatever within this particular window
that you're writing you were bringing up
the weaknesses that you had was weak
again today felt bad again today this
happened the game today and on top of
that it's this complete just opening up
with the of every single emotion that
you had I found it I found it quite
scary to read in a bizarre way like in a
very beautiful way it was it was quite
scary to read because it reminds you of
all of the things all of the fears all
the mistakes that you make in those
sorts of situations and it was oddly
very familiar as well so yeah it was a
unique experience to read yeah that part
is interesting and there's a very strong
reason why it's there and it actually is
very effective because the first part of
the book is basically designed to show
you just how easily is possible to love
yourself no matter where you come from
and you know showing like look basically
the overview of how I did it the second
part of the book is okay
step-by-step manual because it's all
working on the inside on the mind here's
a step-by-step manual so simple just do
this and really within weeks you'll you
know you'll feel it you'll be like
living it right but the third part is
actually we learn best from stories
right so I've showed you from the food
you like look it's really possible for
my life second now I've taught you how
to do it step by step how I do it and
how it's worked for all these readers
from the previous version but the third
is like look but it's an internal thing
right now watch it happen internally
watch me deal with my own demons watch
me go through something hard and this is
honest-to-god true every single word in
there is true watch me go through a
really rough time and see how I'm
applying this the point wasn't to share
my my fears insecurities I don't want
the world to know - my fears and
insecurities I mean who the hell does I
mean I'm not that crazy right it's like
oh and I share stuff about my childhood
why do why do I share it I don't want my
friends to know what I went through when
I was a kid you know I don't want my mom
to know some of the things that are in
there right and and the the reason why I
did it was because I get the emails from
my readers and I know what they're
struggling with and I first of all and
everyone thinks they're alone in their
journey and I want them to look you're
not alone I've been through this this is
what I've been through and watch and I'm
the guy who came up with this and who it
applies and watch what I'm going through
and but it's not to show you that hey
everyone falls by to show you how to how
I build myself up and from the inside so
even as I'm building up an ease even as
the insecurities are coming up but the
fears to come out how am I'm working on
it and it's literally what's happening
in my mind so you can see it and and
then as you can see start to see the
changes happen it kind of shows you in a
way that prescriptively I could not show
you right and you can see the nuances
there's a lot of nuances when you work
on the inside that you can the nuances
explain that better in a story you see
them happening so by the time it's done
you truly but um you're done with this
book you truly understand how to do it
and also how it's possible even if
you're going through a storm of your own
the context is so important so a common
analogy that I use is it's the
why motivational quotes on Instragram
don't change people's lives oh god I
know but like whose life was changed by
Instagram quote like I don't get it like
well you know that the problem is that
there is a lot of worth in it you think
this this one single sentence could be
the distillation of a one of the best
minds on the planets life's work distill
down to a single aphorism but because
all that you're seeing is booty picture
booty picture funny cat video Maxim
booty picture booty picture it's like
I'm just huh
I'm not in the the place for this at the
moment you know I'm getting some
retargeted by some website I was on five
days ago and blah blah like I'm not in a
place for it and I think that you're
right context is important it helps you
to understand
yeah and it's honestly the scariest
thing to put out you know for people to
see inside what like you know here watch
me fall apart and watch me rebuild
myself you know and how I do it using
what I've just taught you how to do in
the first two parts the you know the
thing that I'm thinking there is kind of
the story of the unwilling hero so you
think the hero in every story doesn't go
and fight the dragon because he has to
I'm sorry because he can do he does it
because he has to and he has to because
he can and he can because no one else
can if you are the person who can do the
particular thing and there's no one else
to do it then you have to do it and that
duty bears very very heavy on your
shoulders but the fact that you are able
to go and do the thing that helps
everybody else that takes down the
dragon that raises the consciousness of
everyone else that helps them to
transcend their own problems that is why
you have to do it because no one else is
there for you to do it yeah I mean I was
writing that part when I was going
through through that storm and I was and
I was running it more as an exercise to
myself and keeping record obviously it's
been I've edited you know to make it fit
for context
and you but I say that I'm all I mean is
that cut out stuff that didn't belong in
the book right there's the when you
never and you're writing a book there's
a narrative you can have it has to serve
the narrative and it was near the end I
realized oh my god this is the missing
peak to piece of the book cause I was
working on the book and I'd finished I
decided I was gonna be part 1 part 2 but
part 3 was like look that's the missing
piece there's no way someone can walk
over here by the time they finish this
book and it's not being convinced and
knowing exactly how to love themselves
no matter what that was the point no
matter what that's where people get
stuck in their stories but but but but
mine is special we are all special but
like like the inside is still a [ __ ]
show for everyone you know we all go
through our storms no matter how it you
know how great I Instagram posts are
right so it's like it wasn't even being
the word vulnerable I mean like that
gets used a lot and the people use that
but with especially with this book it
was being real like there's not a word
in it it's not true and that's not real
you know and honestly sometimes like I
read him let's go god man I don't want
to leave a footnote like yeah I can't
believe like oh my god this is so
pathetic but like look who hasn't felt
pathetic but the point wasn't to show
you that I felt pathetic the show you
loves how I'm working what I'm doing on
the inside to get over it to get beyond
it to get better because that's what
it's about
yeah yeah it's not a it's not pity party
it's not you signaling with your level
of vulnerability you make oh god no it
could I know it comes across as
transparency and transparency that is
doing like I say laying yourself on the
fire so that other people can walk over
you is kind of the way that it feels to
me well it's also point of like let me
show you how I get better the point is
how let me show you a practical
application of this now it's all in what
I'm talking in theory about what yeah
yeah you going on about no no no I put
this in practice it's seeing the guy
that has the crazy diet or does the
training regime and sings the song and
then goes out and wins the fight does
the race of just
yeah it sound it really i was in fact i
was like partially trying to convince
the publisher that wanted to cut that
last third and that's the one that they
love the most everyone at the publisher
loves the most and they like look you've
done something special that we beg our
authors to do and you've done it in
spades here the level of real you know
like the rebel of transparency that
you've shown is like I was actually at
one point I was like come on let's just
cut this fart let's just like and they
you know it's kudos to them that it's a
it's still there I was scared but that's
when you know you have something real
you know when you're really scared of
showing all of yourself but the point is
not to share show up yourself you look
man this far easiest way to make money
and may and make a living right it's a
matter of what helps the reader what
really supports the reader what
transforms the reader that's the point
cuz there was an original version of
this book that did so well right why
come out with an expand of significantly
expanding it's like four or five times
the size right and yet every word
matters why do that like so if I'm gonna
do that then that's kinda gotta go all
out because I don't want to do another
version after this this is it this is a
soup to nuts version I'm done right I
didn't hold that I didn't hold back here
you know I'm I'm I'm proud of this work
I'm proud of I'm proud of what it's I'm
proud of the people who've supported me
at what the book is gonna do I saw what
the original version did I'm very
curious to see what this version is
gonna do I think in the nicest way
possible you should probably be a little
bit scared I think well it could
terrified might be the word yep they're
actually yeah
I honestly money there's this some
people for whom this will be the message
that they need to they need to hear and
I think again if you are the hero that
has to go and and sacrifice a lot so
that others can live a fuller life so
the others can live in more freedom
without the tyranny of whatever
particular dragon it is that you've
managed to wipe away in their mind I
think that
- really worthy cause I also think it's
an incredibly worthy reason to come back
from the dead that's thank you man I
really do feel like this book is the
reason you know it's coming out soon and
on January 7th and this reason the book
is a reason why I get up in the mornings
now even when I'm in pain you know I get
up because I have a podcast today I get
up because I you know until recently I
was still like I'm you know to the point
where I was like a like even down to the
last like it when the the the blank page
is the insert in the beginning at the
end of the book I was like going back
and forth with the publisher about it
like I cared that much you know it's a
beautiful like it's something that I
actually yesterday I finally got the
hardcover copies they're beautiful the
publisher really went all out Harper
over one like really believes in this
book and you can tell they spend extra
money on the hardcover versions if
anyone's gonna get the book I highly
recommend trying the hardcover it's at
least I'm holding the American version
it's it's stunning and and it's like
it's why I get up these mornings it gets
me up you know like no matter if I'm
feeling pain or whatever I have a duty
to it's not just writing it now a duty
to now put it out to the world it's the
when did not sale mana is it's the kite
that's sort of pulling you through
different baby oil and a single string
that one string threaded woven through
each of the different bits of trauma
that you've had so we've look we've
flirted around it and skirt it around it
this long why is it important to love
yourself look I I one thing I'll be very
clear up I'm not a I'm no expert I'm
just a guy right I go to school I don't
have a PhD and loving yourself that's
really funny I'm gonna use that I'll
credit you forever that's really funny
look I'm not that guy I was a startup
guy I have a guy was in the US military
you know I was an infantry soldier in
the US Army you know I might might the
things when I think about the my
favorite things I've done I've climbed
in the Himalayas you know done like
easy stuff I did you know I like doing
things like that I'm not the guy sits
sits around and says you know I don't
have a ponytail you know like I just
have long hair but I never pony you know
I'm I I don't I'm not the guy was I mean
I was building startups in the valley I
was building companies from scratch you
know I'm a doer I'm I taught myself to
write over years and years and years in
rejection letters like you know studying
the Great's to be a better writer like I
believe in doing and creating things so
I wasn't the guy who was sitting there
thinking this but this was something
that that happened when I hit a bottom
like seven years or eight years ago when
a company had built and that self-funded
after four years fell apart and I lost
everything and you know like hair was I
done well am I done well and I lost
every dime I'd made I was living off
credit cards you know but along with a I
lost my sense of self and I fell apart
and it was the loving yourself was
something I decided to do in a moment of
desperation and it came from something
deeper than me that I didn't even know I
wanted but it came from my desperate
need and I set out to do it because I
believe in the power of commitment I
committed to myself that I would do it
and you know I shown in the book why
that's so important how to make that
commitment because it's a sacred act the
commitment itself is a true sacred act
and when you go all-in you know things
happen right and so I didn't know how to
do it you know I didn't grow up with
that all right so I had to figure it out
but the one thing I've always believed
that is like working if you work on your
inner self you got to work on your inner
self and something in me went deep in
and just started doing things in my
inner self that start to work and when
they worked
I went deeper if they didn't work I
threw them away I didn't care I was
trying to save myself and and out of
that came this like basic practice I'm
loving myself within a month I really
really was and it shifted my life and
over the years I've gotten lazy and let
it go and old patterns and loop start to
run again and insecurities start to run
this show rather than this rock solid
base of just just just full love for
myself and by the way loving yourself
does not mean being a selfish prick
excuse my language
right it's not it's deeper you know it's
it there's a there's a there's a depth
to it
that that goes beyond so you know it's
not selfish it's not narcissistic you
may make you make better choices for
yourself but you don't make the
necessarily selfish choices you make
more thoughtful choices and so it
changed my life it really changed my
life very very quickly to the way it was
like nothing had done anything I had
done a pail to it because it was
completely transformative and so I would
share with friends and then victimís
we'd write a book on it and so like I
purposely wrote a very very very short
book it was like 40-something pages you
know on purpose very short break to the
point I put it out in Amazon
self-publish and it took off it went
viral people will buy dozen copies and
give him out to friends and family as I
get emails from people who said this
stuff literally stopped them committing
suicide I've met some of them and
personally was like lick one man you
know he had a gun in his hand when he
was reading it and like after he ready
he put the gun away you know like I have
plenty of stories like that you know and
then from like young teenage girls to
women in their 70s or senior citizens
and people have like I we don't have
much in common a life experience like
but what we have in common is we have
the human mind the human condition is
the the fundamental foundation we all
have and and it showed me just like look
it's not just me but you know we all
have our own struggles and love is such
a primal thing they are wired for rather
than try to work on 30 different things
working the one thing that matters the
one thing we could always use more off
no one says I have too much love if they
do like bully for you I want to study
from you yeah yeah so I think that's why
like and it's I never said I'm not to
love yourself guy I'm not the guy I tell
you what you are now you definitely you
do not have any choice and if you're not
if you're not the love yourself guy then
bring in another version of this book
out was the wrong idea like I'm not the
guy who set out to be that yeah right
I'm not the guy who was like I'm gonna
teach the world to love themselves no I
was just doing stuff and I was trying to
get better and then I was just sharing
it that's all it was just angry
yeah and you know here's a little here's
a little interesting irony and
so while I was building startups I was
teaching myself to write and I was
teaching myself literary fiction you
know which I want to be a literary
fiction writer and I was writing novels
and that kind of stuff I collected
rejection letters I was studying him
anyway and all the greats you know
started with him and they clean clear
prose like it's much harder to get a
deeper concept with simple words than it
is a deeper concept with large words
right and I was training myself to be
that kind of writer that like anyone in
the world could pick up my book and I'd
be the basic grass completely get what I
write about so I was writing travel
stuff and this and that and like
adventure stuff and so forth and you
know never went anywhere and then when I
wrote wrote the little book because I
had the craft aisle now I could express
what I had to say that little boat took
off and put me on the map as a writer so
interesting right the what I it it's not
what I set out to be a writer for but
because I'd worked on the craft for all
those years and that allowed me to be
able to do this and then this put me on
the map again it comes back to what I
just said before like you don't get to
choose the journey that you are called
to do you don't yeah you don't get you
don't get to choose that if you're the
one that can slay the dragon and you're
like well I'm not a dragon slayer and
you're like well you can so you are grab
your sword you're off and that's the way
it goes
certainly one of the things that it
makes me think about there is Jordan
Peterson's advice about being precise
with your speech and I think that
increasingly as I'm exposed to great
podcasters like Oprah Marcus who's now a
mutual friend of ours he's great man
he's a real deal he is the real deal him
Sam Harris you know the guys that Ben
Shapiro even all of these guys have
different speaking Cadence's they swim
in different waters they talk about
different subjects but the thing which
unifies them is the precision in their
speech there is no more there is no less
than they need it is as lean as is it's
possible it's at one of those Belgium
Bulls and it is just lean powerful
precise speech like a sniper and I think
you know the fact that you had to write
or you chose to write such a short book
meant that there's no time for fluff
there's no time for waffle and
extraneous information and all this
stuff it's not it's just this is what I
mean to say and again I can remember who
it was I was speaking to not a liason I
think from the made you think podcast
and what he said was 95% of self-help
books not putting love yourself in a
self-help category but it's a good
example to use 95 percent of self-help
books are a 5,000 word blog post there
are tweets I was actually talking to the
journalist I was talking I was like look
the thing with self-help and it's kind
of ironic cuz I have now now myself up
writer but I look at myself as a writer
who's writing self-help from his
experience right most self-help books
are read are written by people who want
to be self all people the book is just a
brand thing that they want to get out
it's very obvious you can reread it you
can tell especially if you're care about
the craft of writing right and they
Phillipa things and they fill it with
things that don't serve the reader that
just fills pages you know which is just
lazy you know which is just if you're
gonna put something out don't be lazy
but because I think part of it will be
signaling look if you're gonna spend $14
on a book you want to feel like you're
getting your money's worth and I think
bizarrely getting your money's worth
means looking at a thick book but that's
actually the wrong way to look at it you
want the book to be as short as is
possible
and and effective but you know you can
fill you know a thousand page book and
make it every word effective it's just
it's work it's real work you know that's
the thing so we were told them we were
talking earlier on about the fact that
loving yourself as a transformative
process and it's a commonality between
everyone right it's one of the few
things that we all need to do that's
what you identified and I think I go
back to Alain de Botton from the school
of life who's one yeah one of my
favorite content creators and I can say
he's coming on modern wisdom next year
I've managed
to get him in my inbox so now it's done
next year which would be amazing
conversation and what he says is that
he's referring to depression but this
talks about any negative thought
patterns
he says depression feels like a personal
curse bestowed on us like it's this very
unique pathogen this virus that was
designed and it's fed to us and only us
yeah you might have pain but my pain
special my pain is my pain and you don't
know you can't understand my pain
because it's this and you can't you
can't give me the root out of this
because it's not that and we the fact
that we don't understand how inherently
flawed and vulnerable and terrified and
winging it like how little of a clue
everybody has from the most competent
person that you've seen - the biggest
blunder on the planet no one has a clue
and everyone's just kind of winging it
as we go through life but the fact that
you feel because you're so immediately
aware of your own experience and you get
to see all of your blunders at first you
get to see all of your insecurities you
get to see all of your failures and and
worries and concerns and resentment and
bitterness and all of that stuff you see
at this front row view and the fact that
you're able to see that and yet you only
get a highlight reel of everybody else
makes you always feel like the curses
that you have a personal for you that
bestowed exclusively on you and I think
that trying to find a commonality which
is the wind in that sail it's the kite
that you hold on to that everybody
that's universal I think that that is
really really important well you know it
kind of goes back to what you were
talking about using the metaphor of the
hero it's something I write about in the
book it's like look I think it as an
adult you get two choices whatever story
we going through let's look at as a
story because fundamentally it is
memories aren't facts memories of
stories are in our mind it's it's it's
that there is no facts in the human
brain they're all stories created around
events that are actually very malleable
stories right and and we only have one
simple choice am i going to be hero or
be a victim of this story and it's our
job to create make ourselves hear of
that story and how you make that the
hero of the story is not not the one who
just sits there eating bonbons at the
beach all day the hero the story is one
who steps up makes it stay and says I'm
gonna get I'm good I'm gonna make my
stand I'm gonna be choose something
better do something bigger and get
through this and I'm gonna come out of
it I'm gonna you know whatever I care
for is gonna come out of it that's how
you become the hero
so through all of this we can use this
to become whatever it is we're going
through a life whether it's good or bad
we can use it to become the hero of that
story and then when you start to feel as
the hero of your story when you start to
actually see the changes that you made
and then the effects then talk about
self-confidence talk about how good you
feel about yourself you know and it's
it's all you you know it's a beautiful
thing I love that metaphor using by the
way you know and and it's something I've
used as well and and I were using the
book and I talk about my child and I'm
like look like I you know I could I
could point to all those things say look
I was a victim you know and sure enough
children can get away with being a
victim you know I mean at some point yes
but I'm an adult now
and look what I look what this child
chose to do because of this child I'm
here you know how damn proud I am of
this child and you know he became the
hero of the story and I'm here as a
result of having become the hero man how
amazing so there's a million different
doorways open at the moment in my mind I
want to come back to the fact that the
entirety of the book to me feels like a
letter to yourself or a memoir to
yourself as if it was written by another
you as if it was written outside of your
body and it treat yourself as if you are
somebody you are responsible for helping
write another Jordan Pederson ISM that
the fact that you are able to do you
know there's statistics about dogs
completing their antibiotics courses do
you know this no that's an interesting
thing to bring up there is if you have a
dog the likelihood of it completing its
course of antibiotics given to you is
about 90% the likelihood of you
completing your course of antibiotics
yeah yeah why it's because it's much
easier it's much easier to care for
something else then it is interest
themselves ah interesting why don't we
think about what happens in an aircraft
malfunction you're told to put your mask
on first because when you are
suffocating you are of little use to
anybody else including the ones who need
you the most even though you don't know
that data well you got you got you got
to sort your own ship first and you have
to treat yourself as if you are someone
that you were responsible for helping so
that's one and I want to I want to kind
of come back to how how I think all of
that links in but I had a I had a bad
couple of weeks recently and it was
start last week actually as I began
reading the book and the book was one of
a number of different influences which
occurred at the same time but it was
something that I needed to read and what
I felt at the time was I was very much
at the mercy of what was happening in
life that I'd piled a lot on this
podcast is a absolute labor of love and
it is one of my one of my primary
passions but it is a punishing schedule
to release two episodes a week it is
challenging I have a number of other
businesses I've this that in the other
I'm not singing the war with me song I'm
trying to give you context that's all
and I just it got too much and I was
like look like I just want to I just
want to put my hands in the air I just
want to give up I'm like I'm just I'm
just sick I'm just gonna go Abed I was
gonna go up bad and I'm not gonna bother
checking my phone and I'm gonna feel bad
about the fact that I'm in bed but I'm
gonna do this like that that's me that's
my defense mechanism like that [ __ ] it I
don't need to I don't have a boss I run
my own company I'm single at 31 and
don't have any financial liabilities
that I can do whatever I want and the
company continues to go I don't have any
kids I'm not I'm you know I have no
reason to generate my own meaning during
the day right no reason or also most
people I've got to get up my boss'll
shout at me at work I've got to get up I
gotta get the kids to school I gotta
carry my missus is here and that
structure that they have that help gives
the momentum it gives them that pull
right it's the wind in their sails to
pull them through and I was just like
you know what it is I'm [ __ ] sick of
create I'm sick of getting over my own
inertia
like every morning I gotta get up I
think [ __ ] this sucks there's no one
here telling me like gassing me up like
saying yeah man let's come up let's get
it let's get after it now I've go to the
gym it's still working for you but it's
like now like it's me that has to do
this to myself and if I don't do it no
one is there to say you should have done
it except for me and my own feelings of
loathing and guilt and self referendum
you [ __ ] house why didn't you get out of
bed [ __ ] like this is just I can't be
asked bollocks to it I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna do this and that's like I'm
sort of flip-flopping around just go
into the shop maybe that fart out half a
gym session go home not really do
anything just wallow in being feeling
[ __ ] it's been a while it's been a while
since I felt like that and I was like
[ __ ] this this sucks
like this is this is a place that I
thought I'd conquered I didn't think
that I was going to end up having a deal
with this again again again for the
[ __ ] however much time I'm 31
how is it that life just life what's the
problem Chris oh well um kinda I just
got a little bit too many projects on at
the moment and the amount of agency and
the vastness of choices that my life has
gives to me is it's weighing heavy and
you're like okay there's starving
children in Africa there's people who
were literally bleeding out of their
abdomen and it's spraying everywhere
like a garden hose like in America or
and blah blah blah
hiss frankly yeah that's it like what
what what are you doing that why is this
a big deal and I was just I was so sick
and one of the things that you say in
the book which verbalized something that
I've been feeling for a long time was
talking about how life happens to me a
life happens through me three stages to
me or for me or through me yeah
so it's almost a step by step it's
leveling up yeah and it what what is
that that particular dynamic it's from
victim to actor to hero probably
something in those lines
yeah yeah it's more for the internal
thing and and the expression of it being
external it's something I've learned you
know like life happens to me is I think
seems to be a modus operandi as human
beings be thinking everything happens to
us but that's where victim mindset comes
from and that's a very standard thing
you know with like life happens to me
life happened for for me is that
happened by as I started to love myself
I just felt like life was starting to
just turn like all of it was just
turning in my favor and that's something
that other people notice too as they
start to do this it's very interesting
as within so without you know the old
saying and then I think the next higher
level is you go deeper is it's almost
like you start to feel like like what
your insight is starts to become the
expression starts to become an sorry
you're outside starts to become an
expression of your insight and you
almost feel like you're just flowing
through life and life is flowing through
you and it's and it's wonderful and I'm
not saying it's always easy you know
because we are human beings and be
living in a living a human life but it's
a beautiful play with experienced life
and it it's not one that you force it's
not one that you intellectually say okay
I get it and I'm going it's not a matter
of intellectually getting anything it's
a matter of living it you know so it's
it's something that happens as you start
to do this as you start to and look you
can choose something else but those
loving yourself you can just be just
work on something that makes you better
at the inside and you'll notice the same
things
and we all have we all have gone through
like maybe flow in our life but things
just start to work and if you look at it
it has it's a reflection of your inner
state it is so yeah I'm I'm thinking
about the amount of discomfort and just
general angst and all this sort of stuff
and then I woke up one morning and I was
like you know it is I'm sick like I'm
absolutely sick of feeling like I'm at
the mercy of my life I'm at the mercy of
my thoughts like this is not this is
absolutely not the hero's journey this
is absolutely not the way that this was
supposed to go so I started to reef
things and there isn't there are certain
things that you can do which change
course very quickly I'm hesitant to talk
about like this one thing it came down
from the clouds and that you know I like
her I've changed upon this this single
moment but I was able to reframe my
thinking and it made a very very big
difference very very quickly and one of
the main things was yeah perhaps there
are some quirks of my own consciousness
perhaps there are some quirks of
everybody's consciousness that's
listening and with those come some
benefits with those comes from curses
right like it is both a blessing and a
curse to feel everything so very deeply
the depth of my consciousness causes me
to suffer all of these little aphorisms
that you hear but the point is that this
is the vessel that I've got this is the
vessel I've got this is the mind I've
got and to the people that are listening
it's the consciousness that you are in
that's the one you've got like you know
whether you believe in reincarnation or
something sort of a little bit more
exotic that's cool but right now the
only thing that you've got is the brain
that you living in so you've got to work
with it like the has to be something you
have to make it work because the
alternative is just lying in bed and
eating biscuits and like it that that
sucks
like that's not a cool way to spend a
day so I thought right I need to I need
to really try in and reframe what's
going on and there's some concepts that
came to mind leaning into discomfort
from Ben Bergeron and chasing excellence
where he talks about leaning into
discomfort as if you invited it through
the door it's like a good friend so okay
yeah yeah cool this is this feels like a
little bit a little bit uncomfortable to
me but that's cool this is why I'm here
this is because it's a place of growth
for me and this is part of my process
and the fact of the matter is the way
that I came back to it was yeah maybe I
got to get off my own inertia perhaps
that's perhaps that's just part of life
perhaps it would be great if there was
this big support structure that kind of
brought me through everything
perhaps it would be brilliant if there
was someone gassing me like a hype man
you know like DJ's have got on stage
like just - like yeah man let's get up
there let's go get it
how's about dawn that's that's that's
not the situation that life has for me
at the moment sigh I got to make this
work and I have to work out how I can
make this work and taking control taking
agency over the things that I can't
control because there are some things I
can control and doing that and being
proud of the things that I am able to do
being proud and feeling happy with the
person that I've become and it you know
when you talk about the traumatic
experiences that you've had through
childhood and then putting them out on
display for [ __ ] knows how many people
are gonna read this book like a lot of
people the the fact that someone is
you're prepared to do that I'm like you
need to be able to own everything it is
all of the failings all of the scars all
of the trauma all of they're good and
the bad and you have to because the
alternative is lying in bed eating
biscuits or worse that's look if you're
gonna put something out to the world you
got to give it your best always don't do
it if you want it to last you know
that's one of the I mean the the stuff
that's in that book is there for a
reason you know is purely designed to be
of value yeah so when you when you start
looking at that way it makes it it makes
a choice much easier getting under the
second section of the book which is why
you actually start to talk about the
process would you be able to go through
that would you be able to explain the
process of going through this I'm happy
to you know the one one caveat I would
give is the reason why I wrote the
expanded version was because there's a
process here you know this is a process
that I've refined over the years so to
try to give a quick synopsis I would say
it'd be like telling someone on a
podcast how to do us how to do squats
and deadlifts I would say like you know
like you know if you're gonna do it you
know like really pay attention in the
book is this nuances and those nuances
matter and then make it easier and to
make it faster and then make it last
but front
it all starts it almost it starts with
if you're gonna leave the if you're
gonna go to the future you got to leave
the past behind
so it's an exercise that I've done over
the years to forgive myself a very
simple exercises self forgiveness and it
works and then like everyone I know
who's done it it works it's very simple
and it's literally you start to realize
the weight of what you've been carrying
and it's time to let it go you gotta let
go before you really because now be
stepping into the future where we're
gonna be loving ourselves so you gotta
let go of the past so the first is doing
that exercise then the second is on the
power of commitment you can't just say
okay I'm gonna love myself and then do
you know if when we state things like
this especially what things we're not
used to if you've been eating bonbons
all your life you can say I'm gonna go
you know train for mr. Olympia you know
be mr. Olympia you gotta you better have
a plan of action you better have a
committee give you some serious
commitment right you don't just do go to
the gym when you feel like it and eat
your you know chicken breast and
broccoli when you feel like it you know
whatever mr. Olympia meets you know but
you get you know it takes a significant
commitment and I think for the for the
most importantly for mindset this
fundamentally is a way to like is a
mindset it's a if I can use the word
heart set it's working on your heart on
your mind right that takes the weighted
really shifted fast is to make that
commitment
so I show how to how I made my vow to do
it and how you can make your vow so it's
a forgive yourself make the vow then the
rest is you got to keep your vow and
then the rest is the practice that I you
know off loving yourself and it's a very
simple practice based on how to make
yourself feel it on a consistent basis
and then even little things like you
know throughout the day 10 bratz where
you stop when you make yourself feel and
how to do that and using the concept of
light I found that that for me the
concept of bringing light in as I did
that for some reason always really
helped well you know be wired for love
it wired for light you know so when I go
we'll be wired for and so it's a very
simple practice and you know it
basically involves your breath and some
of your thoughts during the day which
both of which you're gonna be doing
regardless but what you're doing is
you're taking that then monkey in your
mind you're putting
rains on it you know our Legg they say
it's a horse and it's a wild horse and
you're putting rains on it and you're
training it to go where you want it to
go until it eventually starts to walk in
there on its own that's all it is and
it's training it's mental training and
it's not it feels a little foreign in
the beginning because - have you been
taught that you know to just work on the
mind itself but is it is the most
important thing we got it is the one
that affects everything you can have
everything going grand your life but you
could inside feel horrible you know our
vice versa or just be steady you know I
was talking to my brother about this
maybe a month after the whole experience
you know I was like man it's kudos to my
mindset how I'm just like how my state
of mind is through this whole experience
like kudos to the work I've done it
shows you know how my mindset is about
this whole thing
I mean look there's some really hard
moments some really really hard moments
really challenging and you know I get to
them quickly and boom I'm back to solid
you know I you know but that comes from
that comes from like the work I've done
on myself you know it's kudos to that
it's like it's like you know your body
when you work out if you go to the gym
everyday for a year for 3 or 65 days you
know and you're eating like lean and
healthy your body will show there's no
way you can hide never people not gonna
you know you see someone today and see
them 365 days from now and you've done
that they were like oh my god what
happened right imagine the same with
your mind right and then the mind is the
one that starts at all you have to lead
with that mind first you have to have
that mindset that you want to have to
change and what I really like is it's
not the idea of loving loving yourself
is not simply a concept there is a
structure there is a framework that you
can instantiate into your daily routine
into your daily practice you know James
clear atomic habits we do not rise to
the level of our goals we fall to the
level of our systems and that's a system
there that's how you take the concept
this is the system that you follow and
here's a story which drives the
Nayla home with a sledgehammer that's
like the size of a house and shows you
also the nuances you can do that in
stories that you can't do otherwise that
the mind will tune out that you cannot
really get it so like if you hit that
point in your head you know it's okay
you know here's what I need to do why do
you think that so many people aren't
loving themselves naturally I don't know
man
that's the here I think it's part of the
human condition
I honestly don't know like I mean we all
can have theories about it but I can
have theories about my own you know but
like I got to the point like I said that
come my my mindset is more of a doer so
my mind that mindset is how do I find a
solution to this right then trying to
figure out why the problem exists exists
that's theory I could spend a whole
lifetime going there right I just want
to fix it I want practical so that's
that's my bias so - I'm at the point
where I think III remember in the book I
wrote like when I first wrote it when I
was first coming up with it it's like
you know I was I wondered about what my
mind wasn't going to his negative places
but it's like you know when you're on
fire you don't need a lecture than
nature combustion use this one water and
water right and that's what I believe in
like just this like put yourself out of
fire thinking yeah that matters yeah you
know the human condition can be a [ __ ]
show okay how'd it make it better how do
I make myself better you start with
yourself as you see you know the with
the airplane analogy and then you start
to make others better around you just
naturally it's pretty it's really
interesting how that works you make
yourself better the ones around you
start to get better so it's just a
natural ripple effect during the podcast
that I did with Aubrey he used this
analogy that was fantastic and he said
that in order to serve you have to be
fit for service and that was manifest as
you do not serve others from your cup
you serve them from the saucer which
overflows around your cup
Oh interesting that's a that's a very
interesting for interesting if you
haven't saw it your own [ __ ] it's
difficult time yeah the people with DES
yeah anyone like to forgive this thing
the self again is exercise you know it's
like look forgive yourself first if you
you know especially if you never talk
forgive others
well you can't forgive others unless you
able to forgive yourself truly
forgiveness true forgiveness starts
footing with the self when you start
becoming someone who just naturally
forgives themselves you start to figure
out why there's much easier it becomes
more of a natural expression of it and
look forgiveness only I mean the lack of
forgiveness only hurts us we're carrying
enough baggage day-to-day right you
don't need to carry the baggage of the
past there's enough challenges that are
going to come up there's enough things
which need fixing there's enough people
who could who we can help yeah I mean
look we carry enough in us anyway and we
keep on adding more along the way you
know no one's perfect you know like
there's no it's a matter how does it
just be a better human you know but
given the operating system I got how do
I just be better and better I'm better
one of the points that you bring up in
the story is the the fact that you are
annoyed or upset at yourself for being
back in a place that you thought that
you had conquered and also one that you
had essentially become maybe not an
authority on but at least some sort of
leader within the space of loving
yourself and you'd let that slip that is
such an interesting situation I think so
many people who do work on themselves
fall back into old habits but when you
fall back not only have you got the old
habit to deal with but there's the
second order referential guilt of [ __ ] i
thought i thought i'd i thought this was
done were a right all right it was the
first time that i've ever read a story
where someone dissect that
yeah it's at thanks man look I'm human
right I wanted like I I never promised
my own perfection like my faking
perfection serves no one and I wanted to
show like look because I have all have
so many emails from reading our tens of
thousands it's like a significant amount
right now I read them all I respond to
them I've started I've got to understand
what the challenges are I want to show
them like look you're not alone you know
I think as you were to split my
depression it feels so personal and all
of our stories feel so personal I wanted
to say like look you're not alone you're
reaching out to me for advice I go
through the same thing and but this is
what I do to get over it this is what I
do to get better again and again I
return to the same thing and look I'm
the guy who came up with this and look I
stopped doing AI got lazy and and then
you know when something hard happened I
kind of fell apart right and yeah and
and like talk about embarrassing talk
about feeling shame you know like to be
the guy yeah well I never set out to be
the guy but like I wrote the book on it
right like that was from my experience
and I wrote it from my experience and so
I'm going to share that as well like
look like we will there tons when we
will befall what do we do we step up
again and knowing what works and we do
it again and we go back at it that's
part of life there's people who don't
have that rule book is people who don't
have that those tactics those frameworks
to fall back on I've had a couple of
friends over the last few years who have
taken their own lives and thinking about
them they are people who had a
complexity of mind which caused them to
suffer but who didn't have tools to deal
with the suffering that's like a
commonality between them a lot of them
were people who
they wanted they wanted to become better
but didn't have a root out of it they
didn't have something prescriptive they
didn't have that wind in the sail the
kites flying limp and it seems to them
to be only one way out after that yeah I
understand it I've lost friends I've
been there man I've been there close to
it so I understand it's hard it's you
know to be or not to be the ultimate
question right sometimes when you hit
that very close it becomes almost
appealing but it's just another pattern
it's another I said it could not even be
in be addiction to go there you know
like I I have lost friends too it's but
the way you put it was very was wise of
describing like you know a lot of that
they're conditioned so going back to
what we were talking about to do with
viewing yourself as someone else is it's
obvious that we're able to give
compassion to other people that we
struggle with Prasad's we give advice to
other people that we struggle to do for
ourselves
the number of times that I've given
someone a piece of advice that I
wholeheartedly could have done with
heating myself is like it's almost like
you're pretty it's like what it's kind
of like projecting but it's advise
projecting like you're not projecting
your insecurities it's projecting the
answer to your own insecurities or your
own problem onto someone else but you
still don't listen it's so bizarre it's
so bizarre and then thinking about love
yourself like your life depends on it it
almost sounds like a sentence you're
saying to someone else not to yourself
but you can say it to yourself right
yeah I mean if that that sense actually
came from a talk I gave and which
actually led to the writing of the
original version of the book and it
really was I was like look if you go at
it that way it changes your life you
forgot about that kind of intensity like
if you're hanging off a cliff and with
your just your fingers and it's loving
yourself that's gonna save you how does
how hard would you do it that's that's
kind of when you go all-in on things
it's nice trying to say basically
whole concept go all-in commit go all-in
commit go all and you know that's where
transformation happens and so loving you
love yourself like your life depends on
ultimately that's what it is commit to
it like truly commit go all in and watch
transformation happen it's pretty
beautiful there's no reason to do
anything else right you know meaning by
by all provable thoughts of what is
going on in the world at the moment you
have this life there might be something
else there might not but the one thing
that we do know is that we have what's
here and now so why go half in the only
reason is perhaps because it's too
difficult to go all in but that if the
only thing that you need to overcome is
difficulty and that's the difference
between you taking control and life
happening through you or life happening
to you and being the victim and playing
that that role you need to commit I
think I don't see a lot of for
difficulty I'll speak from experiences
self-created a lot of our internal
difficulties are self created stories
right but look it's easy to say that
how's that gonna help anyone you know we
all know that so but look going all in
is the secret in committing going all in
is a secret to greatness you know like
an entrepreneurship and in sports
look at athletes you know how many of
like amazing athletes how fast they're
training all their life you don't get
that why is that you know they're always
outliers they see outliers who change
the world and they're always the ones
who really go all out you can have
talent but talent only get you so far I
might get you early wins but then when
you're in the pros all of a sudden you
know you need way more than talent you
need a lot of practice and skill you
have to have like really worked on your
on your sport it's the same thing with
the inside you know like it
it really is committing and going
all-out or you can use all our all in
you know I when I was editing the book
go through edit process that's like
conferring sometimes use all our system
forwards between it but but you know
it's the concept just go all you be
going all in on something that truly
matters
that's where like magic happens right
and and you know that comes from also
commitment but you have to commit
whether you make a conscious or
unconscious commitment you are
committing if you're going all in and
might as well make it a conscious thing
so then like you learn how to do that
for other things that you may not have
confidence in but you want and you learn
well I'm gonna make a commitment and I'm
gonna keep it it becomes a way of being
it's become a way of being for me and it
says it's really transformative the
ability to make a promise to yourself
and fulfill it I think is such a
powerful and underrated simplistic way
to help people move forward right like
how many people that are stuck in a rut
just struggle that they've broken
promises to themselves so many times I'm
gonna tomorrow I'm gonna start the diet
this week I'm gonna go to the gym I'll
stop smoking and I'll be nicer to my
partner I won't cheat on my part I won't
do this I won't do that but how many
taught and then every time that that
promise gets broken it's like we're
coming back to it being like this to
people you're looking at yourself like
another person say if you had a friend
who was consistently breaking promises
to you you'd be like nah man I don't
trust you you're not gonna do that
you're not gonna you're not gonna you're
not gonna stop smoking you're not gonna
do whatever but the difference is you
can't not have that thought because it's
inside of your own head so that dialogue
begins to make it harder and harder and
harder so I'm a big advocate for
sobriety for productivity so I think
it's a massively underused tool that
people can do to give themselves more
time or more money or more calories to
spend on things they care about
and the thing is that if you in the 21st
century surrounded by a culture where
everyone's partying all the time
especially in the UK like big drinking
culture if you can go sober for 90 days
or six months say like what else can't
you do like the deck of cards just
tumbles after that it's like you you
were the the one person
it was on a night out that wasn't
drinking for six months or you do pick
your point peak your challenge right
like once you've done that one thing
it's alright well hang on
I made a promise to myself and I kept it
[ __ ]
what else can I do what else can I
promise myself that I'm gonna do how
much more momentum can I start to build
her and you talk about this right you
talked about about greasing the groove
about river about carving the the path
of a river and our four outings are
thought patterns being deep and our
thought patterns needing to be recreated
yeah I mean like look you know the
classic neurons that fire together wire
together these are mental loops and
groups that are running the show so it's
about creating like just new grooves
that's that run the show and we gotta do
it consciously we have too many that we
created unconsciously over our lives
it's just it's Tina taking over the
reins and doing it consciously until the
horse walks there you know starts
walking in the direction where you
wanted to do good go naturally that
takes training that the horse doesn't
you just do that on its own right yeah
it's a horse that's incredibly
disobedient incredibly naughty horse but
yeah you know that that idea of making
promises to yourself and keeping them
and having faith in your own word and
having trust a great path to self
confidence you know if you trust
yourself you know like I have a
fundamental trust in myself and that's
like that's something special and how
did that do that you know I just started
making keeping commitments to myself you
know and some and you learned I'm not
perfect sometimes I break them you know
it's a but you like get up and you you
know you recommit and you go out and
again you know you don't quit
all right you don't give up you learn
from it and you recommit and you go at
it again you can go at it again one of
the things that you bring up so the
story at the end of the book is about a
breakup and inherently with that you
need to let somebody else into your life
you need to allow someone to be a part
of your life but what we're talking
about here is loving yourself that's in
be quite an independent thing this is
you on your own how do you marry those
those two things together for the
majority of people listening they will
either have or end up with some sort of
significant other hopefully very happily
for a long time but they also need to
have that framework in place that is
just them but they need to be
sufficiently open to allow that other
person to permeate into it how did those
two are this there's nothing there's
nothing opposing a major that one's just
a way of being and when you're loving
yourself you'll be way more loving to
others naturally you're way more
accepting your way your I mean you just
are there's nothing you know that
doesn't fit there it's not being
separate for someone it's not taking
time away from someone it's just a way
of thinking a way of being inside and
that's nothing to do with we have enough
thoughts about ourselves inside all this
is doing is just channeling it to
something that serves you and serves
your life and if it serves you in a such
a positive way it's gonna serve the ones
you're around you know it just is
there's nothing about it that's not
compatible you know no matter what even
if you're like wrapped around someone
24/7 you're still gonna be having your
thoughts you're still in your head and
so what's gonna be happening inside that
head what's gonna be happening inside
that head when it's a shitty day you
know not all days are great days you
know what's gonna be what's gonna be the
solidness in there that's yours that's
your choice and that's for you to work
on and like when you work on that making
that better like who you around who you
wrapped around 24/7 you're better with
that person it's easy to see the problem
that you came up against and I have as
well many times you call it coasting I
got comfortable so I coasted or lazy
yeah yeah I got I got comfortable psych
hosted I I no longer did the practices
that I know that are good for me and
it's easy to see how
happens right and the particularly
interesting thing about your story is it
is for many people rug flip day is the
nightmare scenario it is the number one
thing a partner's saying to you you
haven't done anything wrong but this is
no longer happening is it's the the
worst day of their life they do it
that's exactly what they're fearing all
the time and someone being comfortable
before that letting those frameworks go
no longer doing the things which give
them the strength and the structure to
get through a situation like that that's
where that weakness lies right and that
comfort and that coasting before so what
I wondered was the motivation for not
coasting is it out of fear of what might
happen what how does someone continue
when things do get comfortable
how does someone continue to have the
drive from when things were
uncomfortable yeah because that's a
point of Hamor and again and again
because that's been my biggest weakness
and that's been the weakness stuff a lot
of the readers that reach out to me
right so it's like I something I'm gonna
drive home and like that's why I make
this part to the manual creates a
practice out of it creates a consistent
practice that you can do again and again
and creates like very simple things like
the ten brats that you can do no matter
what so you always continue going
forward right is it out of fear no but
after a while it becomes like look I
just want my life to be this way
I want my insight to be this way because
fear only brings you so far you run out
of energy when you you fear can only
take you so far you'll burn out horses
when you're doing is something that's
that just fundamentally is making you
better and but it takes conscious choice
it takes conscious recommitment
and I talked about that too you know you
don't just commit once you don't just
commit when you're 15 to to workout the
gym you like you know you're doing these
unconscious commitments you know were
you stepping up and doing things if you
want to be a better and better shape but
you are doing these commitments and it's
a bicep
recommitting and sometimes you know
you'll coast it's and it's part of being
human but then when you realize it then
recommit and go back at it again because
you will be better and your life will be
better and look if it's out of fear
sometime then all right
use that to drive you but that will only
take you so far commitment is what's
gonna get you it's gonna but fear will
push you and you'll run out is your
commitment pulls you forward you know
there's my commitment to this book that
pulls me forward gets me out of bed I
don't even though I'm you know
recovering it I'm in pain gets me up and
gets me doing what I need to do no
matter what it's not fear if you want to
do that fear won't get you off narcotics
and that easily and they're alluring man
I'll tell you joking Amazon tell me tell
me tell me what it's like what were you
taking or what were you given and what I
wasn't I was on everything I was on like
severe IV and narcotics and and oral a
combination all the time and you need it
cuz your ins you've been split open man
you know they split you open and when
they go and like to save your life it's
not it's you need it you're in bad pain
other this it dulls the pain it dulls
you it dulls the pain now I have friends
of mine who found out that I have some
you know they're like oh can we have
some because they they call them happy
pills and I can see that I guess if
you're not in pain then it just kind of
like dulls whatever else and you can
just be flow be floaty so I can see that
and but I won't I refuse to touch them
though because like the moment for them
past and and there is a you can see the
allure like if you're just I just want
to be floaty and not care you know like
I can see the allure especially if you
don't have if you don't have something
pulling it forward I can see the allure
for that more and more and more you know
I can see why these things there's a
note this is severe opioid crisis in the
United States it's in like severe
poverty areas where the industry is gone
and people don't have much hope you know
and often people are in emotional pain
you may start off a physical pain but
then these also dull your emotional pain
and so then it's very hard to do then
get off it feeling feelings is hot
well it's it's hard yeah it's hard but
it's also yeah it's hard but then also
feeling good feelings is also nice you
know that's the thing that the lows give
the highs right like I don't have to
give the highs listen I don't like that
because you don't have to always be
hitting bottom to hit high but they do
give you they do show you they they make
you appreciate the highs more right I
mean I don't think you can you can you
if you're gonna numb your feelings I
mean you're numbing the top and the
bottom all right let me rewrite let me
rephrase that you have to risk the
ability for you to go low to allow you
to be able to go high with your normal
feelings your perfectly correct that
whatever the range is you're nerfing top
and bottom right you don't get to feel
the happiness when you're on particular
narcotics but you also inoculated from
feeling the lows and for some people
that middle section is just safe enough
it's fine like yeah you you have this
pleasantness of narcotics and you can a
less caring you know let's giving a [ __ ]
you know which I give there you can see
this by I'm look I'm just giving my own
experience on it now keep in mind mine
was also like I was a significant amount
of pain so like part of it but that
whole dark I was just going to dull the
pain you know so I may not be the best
person to give a full experience
breakdown on it but what I do know is
that it
I needed my mind to work what's
something I had to do that was so
important to me that that was more
important than dulling whatever needs to
be dealt as you've said if you didn't
have that what does it leave you with
pain that needs to that needs to be
taken away yeah cuz it's very easy you
know urine mints pain they give you this
blue Modell's down you know who would
say no right yeah yeah I I like I say as
I as I read through this the the
transparency was something that was
quite shocking in the nice way
especially towards the the latter part
of the book talking about all of the
different failings all of the different
problems that you'd come up against all
of the different weaknesses the woke up
this morning and was week texted her
again like that those short sentences
you just I felt the emotion that I've
been through in those situations coming
through with that and the main the key
message there was what you brought up at
the beginning which is we all have these
failings this is not a personal curse
that's bestowed on you all of us are
challenged and terrified and winging it
and confused and scared and lonely and
all of the rest of the things and it's
our job to try and transcend that it's
our job to try and come up with
something which helps us get pasta we
have to become the hero of our story our
choice it really is you know commitment
and going all-in on tomorrow today has
been fantastic manna I really really
appreciate you coming on January 7th you
say direct correct Amazon why can people
hassle you online if they need to hassle
you my email address is in the book
drop me an email you'll find me in the
usual social media you know yeah reach
out amazing month
um so links to love yourself like your
life depends on it
will be in the show notes below links to
come all socials will be in there as
well and if you need his email address
by the book I think that's a fair trade
look i-i've really enjoyed this man I'd
love to get you back on next year and
know that the listeners will want you
back on as well so no let's let's try
and organize a day and we'll have
another discussion let's do it I'd love
it be very curious to see how next year
it'll be awesome month thank you so much
for your time my pleasure thank you
[Music]
you